hi everyone thank you so much for coming
here today and big shout out to the
organizers for putting this event
together I'm very honored to get to be
on this stage and talk to you about some
really serious stuff in 2016 the most
pressing topic of the year for software
engineers was empathy and in 2017 the
topic of the year was inclusion and this
year the topic seems to be about ethics
which I'm really excited about because
the discourse grows more and more
concerning each day and even though
these issues feel like new wounds they
have a long history steeped in bias and
systemic oppression and we need to pay
attention to these things data and
society Research Institute recently
hosted author of algorithms of
oppression professors Sofia
Umoja Nobel to talk about dated
discrimination and technological
redlining and at the event Nobel
reflected on her upbringing in Fresno
California she recalled seeing the KKK
and their garb in public neighboring
sundown towns that enforced the sunset
curfew on black people the black poor
side of town who is a food desert which
meant that there were no grocery stores
at all and with the buses not servicing
the town after 7 p.m. that meant that
there was a huge burden placed on the
poor and the black people of Fresno
California and her talking about that
history and having grown up in that
environment and how it shaped her to be
the person who she was and pushed her to
do the research that she did to publish
the book algorithms of oppression
reminded me about the Forgotten New York
City neighborhood of Manhattan town so
in 1905 Phillip Peyton jr. also known as
the father of Harlem broke the color
line below Columbia University when he
began purchasing real estate on the
Upper West Side on 99th Street and then
98th Street between Columbus Avenue and
Central Park West
there were a lot of notable residents of
Manhattan town including some of the
most venerated artists and intellectuals
of the Harlem Renaissance and one of my
favorite little tidbits was of like
trivia facts was that Sadie Fagan the
mother of famous jazz singer Billie
Holiday ran a cafe in Manhattan town
called mom holidays where she famously
got in an argument with Billie over
wanting to borrow money and that is when
Billie came up with the title of the
song god bless the child but by 1955
those two blocks on 99th and 99 and 98:8
were nothing but rebel in 1949 President
Harry Truman signed the Housing Act and
title 1 of the Housing Act gave Robert
Moses in his position as chairman of the
New York City slum clearance committee
the power to condemn buildings and steal
land under the guise of urban renewal
Moses would then grant the land to
companies of his choosing often is a way
to amass political favor Manhattan town
was literally the very first
neighborhood that Moses picked to do
this to residents of Manhattan town were
evicted in 1951 the buildings were torn
down and most of it was just rubble
until the 1960s when the park West
Village Apartments were built movin
Moses did or ever Keable social
socioeconomic damage by forcing more
than 300,000 families out of their homes
in the 1950s and 60s in the name of
urban renewal here on Google Maps you
can see the two blocks are gone and in
their place are the park West Village
Apartments and a Whole Foods Market
today we talk about displacement of
low-income people through gentrification
but gentrification is not strictly
restricted to socio-economic play in
April of this year Sahid Vasile was
killed by the New York Police Department
in Crown Heights as a consequence of
gentrification and tech has been
directly responsible for the
gentrification of pretty much all of San
Francisco and
directly it has made it easier for the
local culture in neighborhoods like
Highland Park Englewood and Boyle
Heights in Los Angeles Little Havana and
Miami and much of Brooklyn in New York
to be digitally erased by prioritizing
commonly searched terms that gain
prominence when we use Google to search
for things we teach those machines that
that is the priority and since many
times low-income people don't have
access they don't have a need to Google
for something that means that when
there's more attention paid to to a
neighborhood when gentrification starts
happening the software that we are
writing is backing that up so algorithms
with the help of machine learning are
not objective they're instilled with the
biases by the people who write them when
measures are not taken to consider the
consequences of disruption this is why
we need to apply more scrutiny when it
comes to whether or not the features we
push his software our ethical sarch our
theory of existentialism dictates that
humans create their own values and
determine their own meaning for their
life to Sartre once an oppressive
situation is regarded as such by those
who feel oppressed so that the situation
becomes intolerable we are then
compelled to project our intentions onto
our present condition and transform them
into action and because ethical dilemmas
disproportionately affect
underrepresented minorities it's
important to take the time to listen to
us instead of just assuming what we need
some of the most pressing dilemmas right
now are surrounding the issues of
privacy surveillance data and
discrimination of course we've all heard
about the way that Cambridge analytic
unethically used Facebook's data but
there are even more serious things
happening right now especially in the
United States the stop LAPD spying
coalition recently released a report
about the harassment and mistreatment of
low-income black people due to the use
of predictive policing software by
Palantir that they sold to the LAPD and
nearly secretly sold to the New Orleans
Police Department
amazon is also trying to get into the
business of [ __ ]
predictive policing with their product
recognition it has the power to identify
people in real-time photos of large
groups of people and in crowded events
and public places and most notably they
include race as an identifier which
results in increased bias none of these
issues are new in 2016 ProPublica
uncovered bias in the North Point
compass software compass stands for
correctional offender management
profiling for alternative sanctions and
it used it's used by courts to
automatically determine if sentencing
based on criminal recidivism scores that
are set by questions that have extreme
bias against low-income black people so
how do we prevent this kind of
discrimination how do we prevent our
software from ending people's lives we
need to agree on what the ethical
foundation of our work is in this
industry in the workplace and in the
world in 1985 James more detailed in his
essay what is computer ethics these four
tenets it's our responsibility to apply
these tenants to the workplace and ask
these questions when we talk about
machine learning AI and data collection
just to name a few
according to Professor Margaret and
Pearce she defined the fault the need
for the following three ethical
influences an individual personal code
an informal code of ethics and a ethical
conduct or I'm sorry an informal code of
ethics and in code of ethics in the
workplace because unlike our code we
can't say that we were only taking
orders or as Hannah Arden called it
rationalizing in the way of the little
Eichmann's I'd like to remember that
when we talk about ethics the root Greek
word is ethos which translates to habit
or custom and
that is the key to developing an ethical
framework because we need to be
accountable we need to make it a habit
we need to make it a custom in the essay
moral machines by Wendell Wallach and
Colin Allen they wrote about how machine
ethics will drive advancement in human
ethics by forcing us to address gaps in
modern normative theories of ethics this
is our moral imperative it's our job to
consider the ways that our actions are
shaping the ethical world here are some
organizations with their own formal
codes right now in the United States the
only CS programs that require ethics are
the ones that are a B et accredited but
the Association for computer machinery
ACM is considered one of the most
appropriate for web development I urge
you all to look up all six of these and
pick one apply it to your work apply it
to the decisions that you make
practicing ethical decision making in
the workplace is about stretching your
imagination the EF F recently published
a science fiction story by Cory Doctorow
to challenge us to consider the
implications of section 1201 of the DMCA
and how coming down hard on copyright
infringement will change society but
it's important not just to think about
these issues it's important that we act
on them if you remember Robert Moses the
man who basically pushed all of those
people out of Manhattan Ville his legacy
was extremely far-reaching he was most
notably a big fan of the automobile and
he wanted to build a highway that would
run right down the middle of Washington
Square Park and carve up the middle of
the park carve up the middle of the
neighborhood and just send trucks and
cars right down the middle of the
neighborhood because he felt that
innovation and automobiles were more
important than the lives and the people
in the communities
he was also making a lot of money for a
lot of other people and felt that that
was more important than the people who
were living in these homes but he was
stopped there's Washington Square Park
if you've ever been there has no highway
running through it and that's because of
this person this is Jane Jacobs she was
a writer she most notably published a
book called the death and life of great
American cities and she was a activist
in New York City when Robert Moses came
to that neighborhood when he came to
Washington Square Park Jane Jacobs
organized the people of the neighborhood
and put together action like activism to
keep Robert Moses from enacting his plan
Jane Jacobs was really good at the
photo-op she put moms with strollers in
the middle of the park to protest and
she had a ribbon retying ceremony in the
park to mock Robert Moses's
ribbon-cutting ceremonies that he would
do when he opened new highways and
bridges and because she rallied all of
these people and participated in civil
disobedience got arrested for protesting
and at City hearings the mayor was
forced to stop these plans that Robert
Moses had to build a highway through the
middle of the park and what ended up
happening was he went on and he tried to
continue to do this and as he continued
to try to do this in other neighborhoods
tried to carve the middle of Canal
Street down later on in New York City
and Jane Jacobs came back and pushed him
down they kept and got to maintain the
living that they already had they were
able to defend themselves and we
recently saw this happen to in our
industry because yeah just yesterday
Google our Gizmodo reported that Google
will not be pursuing a renewal of their
contract for project maven with the DoD
because of the actions that employees
took over a dozen employees resigned
employees signed paperwork saying that
they did not believe that this was an
ethical decision that they did not want
to participate in dro in writing AI
software for drones and because of this
just like the civil disobedience and the
activism of Jane Jacobs we too can have
an effect on our industry if people
companies are willing to
[Applause]
[Music]
consider how much money companies are
willing to pay to get our attention
how much money they're willing to pay us
in salaries how much money there's
they're spending to sponsor conferences
just like this one we have power over
them as a collective group and we need
to it's our moral imperative to use that
power for good and not for evil and we
need to come up with an ethical
framework to do that that is more
explicit than just good versus evil we
need to decide on codes of ethics the
same way that we decide on codes of
conduct for our conferences codes of
conduct are just ethical codes of ethics
that we apply to our internal group it's
deciding the ways that we want to treat
the people in our society so we need to
apply the same kind of codes to our work
and the world at large it's our job to
design computers to design phones to
design software in a way that no one
dies and to consider the historical
global political social and economic
repercussions of the work that we do so
I want to encourage each and every one
of you to consider the ways that you can
make your work more ethical the ways
that you can prevent people from being
harmed by the software that you write
whether it be through gentrification in
maps whether it be through AI having
bias and machine learning having bias or
even just on your team when your
teammates are the subjective of their
own oppression what are you doing with
your power to help the people who you
work with and the people of the world at
large thank you sir because God will not
have his work made manifest by cowards
you have to be brave you have to take
that responsibility on yourself thank
you
[Applause]